welcome to the opening day here at the
London chess classic it's a day full of
festivities the players get to meet
their fans and give lectures and do
Simoes against the kids once upon a time
I was also inspired by someone so I
think it's a duty to pass it on and what
I really tried to show is the beauty of
the game so if I find something
beautiful I try to I picked that out but
I'm very very happy that so many of them
are playing and I think it's a fine
bunch of kids here it's like a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity and it's
like really fun to learn from the
grandmasters well he kind of sees
everything and he's already calculated
it before you've even said it
he just is too good it's nice to analyze
with someone that's so good at the game
even if you work only very briefly yes
those memories that analyzing with top
GM he just plays without thinking it's
like he's got some engine in his pocket
I think it's cool I mean they're they're
not just fans are also very strong
players in their own right and some of
the best players in the country for
their age group
yeah it just shows us all interesting
points in our game and how to make
ourselves better I for I was going to be
like like if I was talking to like a
celebrity but it's actually you know
it's like I'm talking to like someone
like I know teach also know the
highlight of the day is the probe is Cup
where the top players get to play
against top professionals and one
special player gets included mr. Gary
Kasparov I have to say that it's it's
it's highly unusual experience because
typically we had fairly weak players and
for instance in Paris it was more about
in a who makes the first blunder or so
this time I think we have many strong
players so on the amateur side so the
real players that's it's all about
making blunders but it's just about
playing decent game and it's it's
surprisingly high quality chess
well I think that last year when we ran
this event the pro business cup the
inaugural event of every classic we were
in the RAC Club in PAL mal
the most wonderful chest tradition one
of the oldest chest clothes a beautiful
building incredible decor and rich in
history and yet today were in the
headquarters of Google hosted by the
artificial intelligence company deep
mind and we're in the chest of the
future and the contrast is just
fantastic and yet the vibe and the
atmosphere is just as good it is a very
fun event but it's funny when you get in
there they do take it very seriously
they're you know these guys have got a
point to prove that they're not just
business people they can play chess they
want to impress their partner as well
especially some of the more amateur
business people playing with some of the
best in the world so they are very keen
on putting on a good performance so but
it's great to have them here and you
know the links between the business
world and chairs been well documented
and hopefully this will bring more
attention to the game in sub tournament
it's fantastic when Mickey just then
Gary before it's brilliant for us
amateurs to be able to play sort of you
know such incredible names in in the
game of chess I mean last time I played
who weren't this successful but this
training you know and just as a
difficult game it took time you know to
feel each other's you know moves and I
think the last game we played was a
masterpiece it's great fun because in
the first game he got us a nearly lost
position after moved head in the second
game we were completely lost and then
and then what I like about it is
immediately after that he blames me for
everything it's such fun Britt just
shows you as long as you can have a
laugh and confuse them the old trick
still work it's a wonderful event a
wonderful day everyone comes out happy
as it always is here at the London chess
classic
you